in northern benin humans revere dogs for
their loyalty and bravery but here dogs
also figure in an unusual ritual every
four years the base our baby people
initiate boys into manhood the process a
series of ceremonies including
circumcision hinges on a sacrifice to
honor their ancestors and bolster their
sons courage the base re be kill and eat
a dog this year Enda ITN will lead the
ritual the base arre beloved dogs
especially dogs with brave hearts and
loyal spirits the very qualities people
here hope to absorb when they eat the
animals the soothsayer asks you to kill
a dog so that the boy won't run away in
fear
during the circumcision we don't give
names to the other animals but we give a
name to the dog because he is our
companion
this dog has a name patience for four
years patience has had a good life with
his owner Seiko but Seiko has always
awaited the day of reckoning I follow
the tradition what our ancestors did is
what I do when we bought patience we
knew that we were killing for the fish
beneath the spreading baobab tree stands
the symbol of ancestral spirit the
fetish before villagers can eat their
share of dog they must feed the spirit
with sacrifices ATM's father will begin
the ceremony he appears a parrot with
millionaire and chicken blood the bird
died clearly but patients must live up
to his name ritual requires he be killed
with a club in some sacrifices suffering
is what makes it holy many in the
village know and like patients they'll
miss him not to kill the dog but it is
my sister's who started the tradition
[Music]
Etienne offers the dog's blood to the
spirits out of respect he leaves a piece
of the tail
boys awaiting circumcision dance
readying themselves to eat the magic
meat they believe will awaken the
spirits of their ancestors before an
audience of village elders ATM follows
the preparation ritual animal to the
spirit Etienne offers roasted meat weave
like the rest boils everyone in the
village will want a taste of a
sacrificial meal when you eat the dog
you get good health so everyone wants to
take a little bit go go
once the elders have eaten younger
villagers take their turn they hope the
dogs meat will give them the courage to
endure circumcision and now that the
initiation rite has begun the villages
dogs can rest easy at least for another
four years when the next ritual occurs